this is the earth red sterner sorry
n.com and in this video I'm going to
work some heparin drip calculations and
after you watch this video you can
access the free quiz at the end of the
video that will give you some more
practice problems so let's get started
the first problem says the MD orders
your patient to store an IV heparin drip
at 12 units per kilogram per hour and to
administer a loading bolus dose of 60
units per kilogram IV before initiation
of the drip your supplied with a heparin
bag that reads 25,000 units per 250 MLS
the patient weighs 189 pounds what is
the flow rate so the first thing what we
want to do is we want to take out the
most important information to help us
solve our problem and to do that we have
to know what the problem wants us to
solve for because heparin drip
calculations will ask you to solve for a
wide variety of things this specific
problem wants us to figure out the flow
rate of this heparin drip so we're
trying to get two milliliters per hour
and when I work dosage and calculation
problems if you've watched any of my
videos I do dimensional analysis so that
is the way we will be working these and
we'll be rounding our answers to the
nearest tenth always follow what your
nursing program wants you to round to or
the facility workout because it varies
okay so we're trying to get milliliters
per hour now some important information
that we got from our problem our
patient's weight heparin is weight based
you always want to know a patient's
weight they weigh 189 pounds we need it
in kilograms so we'll be converting that
we also know that the patient needs to
be started at 12 units per kilogram per
hour and we have a bag of heparin on
hand every bag of heparin varies in size
so always read it and see what it says
it says that in every 250 ml is in that
bag there's 25,000 units of heparin so
let's figure out what we're gonna set
this pump at 4 milliliters per hour so
the first thing what we're going to do
is we're going to start out with our
weight remember I'm using dimensional
analysis so patient weighs
and red and 89 pounds okay that's our
patient and we need to get two kilograms
so we know from the metric table there's
2.2 pounds in one kilogram so palin's
cancels up now we're ready to plug this
in that's what the physician orders the
order for the drip to run so for every
kilogram that patient weighs we're going
to be giving them 12 units of heparin
per hour so 12 units of heparin per hour
kilograms cancels out remember we're
trying to get milliliters to hour we're
almost there okay so we have a bag on
hand bag says there's 25,000 units in
that bag of heparin per 250 MLS units
cancels out the more we left with we're
left with milliliters per hour which is
where we are supposed to go so we're
going to multiply everything in the top
everything in the bottom and then divide
so 189 times 1 times 12 times 250 is
what 567 thousand and 2.2 times 1 times
1 times 25 thousand is 55,000 and when
you divide 567 thousand by 55,000 that's
going to give you 10.30 9:09 repeating
and we're going to round to the nearest
tenth so our answer is going to be 10
point three milliliters per hour that is
our answer our next problem says your
patient has a heparin drip running at 24
milliliters per hour the heparin bag
reads 12,500 units per 250 MLS how many
units per hour is the patient
so for this problem what are we supposed
to figure out we need to figure out how
many units per hour this patient is
receiving based on how much is in this
bag and what that flow rate is so we
have a bag of heparin hanging and it's
telling us that in every 250 MLS
there's 12,500 units of heparin and we
have our pump infusing at 24 MLS per
hour so how many units are really going
in per hour so let's set up a problem
using dimensional analysis so we'll
start with the rate that our pump is
running so it's 24 milliliters is going
in over one hour remember we're trying
to get units to our and on hand our bag
that's hanging is a 250 ml bag and it
has 12,500 units in it no liters cancels
out so we're left with units per hour so
we're ready to solve multiply everything
at the top everything at the bottom and
then divide so 24 times 12,500 equals
300 thousand and 1 times 250 is 250 then
300,000 divided by 250 equals 1,200 so
1,200 units per hour is what is infusing
on this patient our next problem says
your patients recent PTT is 42 according
to protocol you need to increase the
heparin drip by 2 units per kilogram per
hour and administer 30 units per
kilogram IV bolus you will recheck the
PTT in 6 hours the patient is currently
receiving a heparin drip at 16 units per
kilogram per hour from a bag that reads
25,000 units per 250 MLS the patient
weighs 163 pounds how many units will
the patient receive as a bolus and what
will you change the flow rate to
this problem we have a couple things we
have to solve for number one we have to
figure out how many units we're gonna
give as our bolus then we have to figure
out what's our new flow rate going to be
because they're PTT came back where it's
not therapeutic so we've got to adjust
that heparin drip so we can hopefully on
the next blood draw get their PTT within
range so looking at that problem what's
the important information we need to
glean okay number one our protocol tells
us because their PTT wasn't therapeutic
then we're gonna have to increase the
drip by two units per kilogram per hour
it also tells us that because their PTT
wasn't therapeutic that they're going to
get a 30 unit bolus per kilogram so
every kilogram that patient weighs
they're going to get 30 units their
current pump right now the pump is
currently running at 16 units per
kilogram per hour but we want to
increase that and why are we gonna
increase that by two units so let's just
go ahead and put that there so we won't
forget so 16 plus 2 is 18 so we're we
wanting to get is 18 units per kilogram
per hour that's the new dosage that they
need now what we have we have on hand a
heparin bag that reads for every 250 MLS
there's 25,000 units and our patient
weighs 163 pounds so let's do the
easiest part first let's figure out how
many units we're gonna give them as
their bolus heparin is weight based so
we need to figure out there waiting
kilograms so 163 pounds is how much our
patient weighs we know from the metric
table that there's 2.2 pounds and 1
kilogram so go ahead solve that 1 times
1 is 1 63 + 1 times 2 point 2 is 2 point
2 so 163 divided by 2 point 2 equals
seventy four point zero nine zero
nine repeating and we're going to round
to the nearest tenth so 70 4.1 kilograms
is how much our patient weighs so for
every kilogram that patient weighs they
need 30 units of heparin for a bolus so
we're just going to multiply that by 30
and 70 4.1 times 30 equals two thousand
two hundred and twenty three units so
that is how much of a bolus they're
going to get now let's figure out our
new flow rate okay patient now because
we're increasing it from 16 to 18
because they need two extra units so
we're going to start with our weight so
163 pounds number one there's 2.2 pounds
and 1 kilogram and our new order is for
every kilogram patient weighs the doctor
wants them to have 18 units per hour so
18 units hour and pee on the kilogram
all that had cancel out now on hand we
have this bag so 25,000 units equals 250
MLS units count cancels out and we need
to get 2 milliliters per hour so we're
ready to solve so multiply everything at
the top and the bottom and divide so 160
3 times 1 times 18 times 250 equals 730
3501 times two point 2 times 1 times 25
thousand equals 55,000 then we'll divide
that 733 thousand five hundred divided
by 55,000 equals thirteen point three
three six three six three repeating and
we'll round to the nearest tenth so
thirteen point three
liters per hour is our new flow rate
okay so that wraps up this review over
heparin drip calculations thank you so
much for watching don't forget to take
the free quiz and to subscribe to our
channel for more videos